the jurogan experience so
john kavanagh who's conor excuse me
who's conor mcgregor's uh
coach said that that's laura laura senko
is
one of the ufc uh commentators and she
uh did an excellent interview with
kavanaugh and they went over
all the things that happened and one of
the things that happened in training
camp was uh
they think it probably cracked in
training camp
and uh he got it scanned and uh you know
they said
there might have been something there
but it's hard to tell it's probably some
sort of a hairline fracture
and uh they did their best to just stay
healthy until they get into the fight
but if you go to laura's interview it's
really excellent and
kavanaugh explains that and it looks
like uh
john wayne parr picked up something too
it looked like the
the shin was compromised on one of the
leg kicks too
not the one that dustin thought dustin
thought that
probably it was probably damaged more
than once because uh dustin
checked one of the kicks and then
pointed to
conor's shin like i know that hurt that
hurt you
but this one this is from john wayne
park's page he throws his kick if you
watch
connor's shin see look it kind of
buckles right there
see that oh yeah no there's that's
definitely good something's right
and now right after it buckles there
this is what john put up
right afterwards conor then throws a
front kick
and that's it right there and that front
kick hits the knee now as it puts it
down
his knees his shin is shot now now he
goes to throw a punch
he throws a punch and then as he steps
back then he doesn't have it on his if
you go to mine you'll see that
if you go to mine go to my instagram and
you'll see
um i reposted it from uh
eric nixik from um
uh extreme couture so he's he throws
this
front kick and as he throws the front
kick it hits
the elbow at the points he's throwing it
up
see that and bam it catches it and then
it goes down and right now he's standing
on that fractured so he puts it behind
him watch
he puts it behind him and then he throws
the punch and then when he goes to throw
the punch
he picks the foot off the ground right
here's the left hand
that almost looked like it but watch
this it did bend back but watch this
bang then it just gives out completely
see it folds over
wow so it was snapped
above the ankle it wasn't actually the
ankle it was above the ankle
here's what's really crazy there's been
so many fights in the ufc
and to have all these breaks in a row
there's been uh jacqueline souza got his
arm broken chris weidman got his leg
broken
there's been a ton of breaks over and
over and over again over there
something's going on just people are
getting good at breaking people's bones
people like that's really what it is you
know and the chris weidman was a freak
accident the craziest thing is
chris weidman there's only been i think
one two three four there's been four
leg breaks like that in the ufc in the
history
of the ufc chris weidman's been involved
in two of them
the odds are insane insane anderson
silva threw a kick he checked it
anderson broke his knee
he threw a kick uriah hall checked it or
anderson broke his leg rather he threw
it
uriah hall checked it he broke his leg
crazy that's crazy the odds
the odds of these things happening like
in this this
number are nuts that is crazy catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience